TOM MELENDEZ: OK, so
I'm playing this game.
I'm right up to the point where
I'm going to take on the boss.
I've been down this road
before, and I haven't succeeded.
But this time, I'm
feeling really confident.
I think I can do it this.
And just at that
moment, I get paged.
DYLAN SILVA: Oh,
come on, really?
TOM MELENDEZ: OK, OK, OK, that
was a flashback from yesterday.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Tom Melendez.
I'm a satellite
operations wrangler
controlling a small
fleet of satellites
taking ground images of Earth.
As part of my job,
sometimes I have
to make remote software updates
to these satellites or even
our ground control systems.
I also manage the
software and systems
used to process our image
data, along with a website that
lets you see these images.
Today, one of our
satellites needed
a hotfix applied right away.
I'm going to show you how I
used Ansible and Google Cloud
Platform to apply this hotfix.
Ansible is a simple-to-use and
powerful IT automation engine
that handles provisioning,
orchestration,
and configuration of
all of your IT needs.
And here to help me
explain this is Dylan.
He's a product
manager at Ansible.
DYLAN SILVA: Thanks for
having me here, Tom.
I'm really, really
excited to see
how you're going to use Ansible
to work on in a satellite.
TOM MELENDEZ: So the
first part of patching
a satellite is to make
sure we have a good build
and that we test it out.
We're going to use
my local laptop
and Ansible to spin up a Google
Compute Engine VM for this.
First, make sure you have a GCP
project, the GC API is enabled,
and a service
account created with
the appropriate permissions.
Be sure to download the
JSON credentials file.
DYLAN SILVA: And then,
obviously, you're
going to need Ansible
installed on your laptop.
So we're going to have you
go to ansible.com and hit
our Get Starting page to
install Ansible by using
the instructions there.
TOM MELENDEZ: Since
I was paged, I'm
going to get the provisioning
test and push process started.
And then we'll take a
look at the configuration.
I have an Ansible playbook
I can use for this.
And all I need to do
on my laptop is type
"ansible-playbook
push-camera-parans."
And while that's
working, Dylan, do
you want to walk us through
the playbooks of it?
DYLAN SILVA: Yeah, sure.
So an Ansible playbook is
a human-readable format
to holistically
describe an environment.
In those playbooks, you have
tasks that are, by default,
executed sequentially in
order from top to bottom.
And those tasks call
Ansible modules.
And what modules are are the
tool kit in the language.
They are what extends
Ansible and the simplicity
of the engine itself.
So based on what
I'm reading here,
I see that you have a way for
us to easily develop and test
against a satellite.
First, a GCE VM is
being provisioned.
And you're also pulling
in some variables
from external files,
which are allowing
you to use those
values without changing
the playbooks themselves.
TOM MELENDEZ: Right, Dylan.
We use that technique
throughout our playbook
so they can be
version-controlled, as well
as be used to build
different environments.
As you see in our
GCE task, we wouldn't
want to check-in our
credentials into source control.
That would make the
playbooks inflexible
and possibly allow for misuse.
DYLAN SILVA: And what are
some of the other options
that you're specifying here
for the GCE module, Tom?
TOM MELENDEZ: Well,
we can specify
one of more instances that
we want to be created,
as well as their zone.
We also are specifying an
image, which in our case,
is a custom Debian image that
includes our camera test.
DYLAN SILVA: And I also see
that you have a post task
to wait for SSH to come
alive before moving on
with the playbook.
That's a really good
convention to go with.
TOM MELENDEZ: Let's have a
look at the playbook that
runs the test, shall we?
DYLAN SILVA: Sure, I'm
really anxious to see
what else you've written here.
All right, so what
we have here is
tasks that is being used to test
some binaries, it looks like.
You're running a command
using the command module
and pulling in some
variables associated to host
from various variable files.
TOM MELENDEZ: You'll
see, for hosts,
we've explicitly set that
value to the group name
from the previous playbook.
DYLAN SILVA: OK.
And then based on
that, the nice thing
is that camera test instances
can be as few or as many hosts
as you really need.
So this playbook will only run
those tests against the host
that you specify.
No change is necessary.
That's pretty cool.
TOM MELENDEZ: Now, assuming
the tests have passed,
we can actually push
the camera configuration
to the RGS, which
will then send it
to the satellite
on the next pass.
DYLAN SILVA: And to
do that, it looks
like you took advantage of a
couple of community modules
to write out that data.
And you also have written
your own custom module
that doesn't come
with the Ansible
to push the data
to the satellite.
TOM MELENDEZ: Correct.
Our updater code
requires an NE file.
So we use the NE file
module to create it
with our camera parameters.
Then we created a custom module
that validates the parameters
and hands them to the binary,
which submits them to the RGS,
returning to us the status
and the encrypted string
for debugging.
Building the custom
module was easy.
And we just placed it in
the library directory,
and Ansible picked it up.
DYLAN SILVA: Cool.
TOM MELENDEZ: All
right, let's go back
and step through the output
from our Ansible playbook run.
DYLAN SILVA: Yeah,
let's do that.
TOM MELENDEZ: You can see that
it did just what we expected.
We used Ansible to spin up
a GCE VM, run some tests,
deploy a hotfix to our
satellite, all from my laptop.
DYLAN SILVA: Cool.
And now you can get back to
that game and beat that boss.
TOM MELENDEZ: I was
thinking the same thing.
Thanks for watching
us today, folks.
We'll be back soon to show
you a few more fun things
you can do with Ansible
and Google Cloud Platform.
Thanks for joining
me today, Dylan.
DYLAN SILVA: Thanks
for having me, Tom.
TOM MELENDEZ: And don't forget
to check out all of our Ansible
modules at the URL below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]